hello everyone and welcome to everyone's
favorite tournament
uh it's uh the park champs and it's a
very nice game between charlie and
ludwig here uh i didn't go through all
of the games
this is the first one that i checked and
it features my favorite line of the
scandinavian defense so i decided to
show this one
and i made a poll some six days ago
asking you guys if you were interested
in seeing some games from the
champs and most of you were interested
uh but not maybe all of them and
maybe just some of the uh some of the
nicer ones from the later parts of the
competition
and uh a lot of you were interested in
voting i don't i don't think i've ever
had uh
a poll this visited over uh over a
hundred thousand of you actually voted
on this poll
uh so this is the first game that i'm
showing from pogchamps
like i said as it features my favorite
lion of the scandinavian defense and
there's a uh there are a lot of
different uh opinions on
whether uh pogchamps is good or not but
the bottom line is it brings more people
into the game
and that that can only be a good thing
in the long run
uh but i've seen uh yanni ponch's tweet
uh that's been circling around i know if
you've seen it um
nepo said that with all respect towards
chess.com and the amount of work they
put into promoting champs
uh chess park champs three uh as uh
popcorn stuff is replacing and
displacing any real chess content and
this is just terrifying so
we've already had this discussion and uh
it will probably happen
every time there's another pogchamps
championship or there
there's a different tournament that's
called the well
who knows what but the fact of the
matter is it is bringing more people
into the game and it is a good thing in
the long run
so uh let's check out the game we're not
gonna do well too too much into any
controversies
uh charlie with the white pieces opens
with e4 and this is what i said and why
i chose the game
uh ludwig goes for d5 or i've seen
people call him ludwig so i guess it's
ludwig
and he goes for the scandinavian defense
with e captures queen captures
uh and now knight the c3 attacking the
queen and we usually
say that uh here you can play queen a5
you can go queen back to the eighth and
queen to d6 is what ludwig plays
and it is my favorite line of the
scandinavian also the reason i chose
this game
uh not so long ago okay maybe even a
year ago i made a tutorial on how to
play this opening so if you want to
check that out it will be the first link
in the description below
so charlie continues developing we have
d4
knight to f6 and now knight to f3 and
here lobby goes for the exact setup that
i actually recommend he plays this
a6 and knight f6 line and black has some
a very
very natural development you want to
place your knight here you want to place
your bishop to
f5 or g4 and you want to castle queen
side and at the right moment you want to
execute
this e5 idea so let's see how he does
this we have bishop to d5 by charlie
continuing development knight to c6 and
now
as the d4 pawn is attacked twice the
bishop has been developed to d3
here we have knight to e2 now both of
the knights are defending this pawn
and here bishop to g4 just continuing
development
you could also strike in the center with
e5 but
that's uh if you want to trade
everything off but it is perfectly fine
for example knight captures knight
captures pawn captures queen captures
and now we can just castle king side and
then maybe bishop to d6 already
threatening checkmate so in all of these
lines black has
very very uh natural development a
bishop therefore
not possible as the b2 pawn falls and
it's a
it's a very tricky tricky line but uh
aladdin
decides to keep uh material on the board
he goes to bishop to g4 now it's
threatening to ruin white's pawn
structure here with bishop captures on
f3
we have bishop to f4 charlie develops uh
with tempo the queen is under attack and
now
queen back to d7 always a dangerous
thing putting your queen on d7 in this
line of the scandinavian
as the knight from f3 will always have
this knight the e5 jump so you have to
uh you you have to uh make sure that it
it isn't the problem for you so maybe
queen to d5 was was a little bit better
here but okay
we have c3 now strengthening the d4 pawn
and here uh ludwig
castle's queen side he doesn't want to
ruin white spawn structure just yet for
example captures captures and then queen
side castles
uh white's probably gonna move the queen
and then also castle queen side so
although the pawn structure is ruined uh
not uh he's not interested in doing that
so he just continues with his
development he castles queen side
and now h3 even inviting uh black to
ruin
the pawn structure and uh ludwig ignores
this with bishop to h5
and here we have castles so now charlie
actually castled king's side and he
invites ludwig
to ruin his spawn structure but a lot of
it's still not interested although here
here you should definitely go for it
captures captures and
as the king already is in the king side
it does make sense to
uh to bust open uh the the king side
even g5 is an idea if bishop captures
rook g8 will be deadly and if let's say
you move the bishop queen capture so
it's a it's a very nice attack that's
happening
uh but instead after this castle we have
e6 just preparing to bring the bishop
into the game
and now g4 uh pushing back the light
square bishop and here ludwig decides
that it's time to
uh sacrifice it's time to go for some uh
for some throbbing action
uh we have knight capture sanji for h
captures and bishop captures on g4 so a
classic uh sacrifice on the king side
where you give up one piece for for two
pawns and
a a nice attack here so hopefully you
can start pushing some pawns
and maybe activate uh uh activated this
rook maybe you can start pushing this
pawn maybe
uh it all depends on how white it
defends and the another thing is this is
a rapid game both
players start with 10 minutes on the
clock and it's always easier to
attack than to defend in chess only only
in top level chess
is uh you know are people well versed in
the art of defense
but when you're still not at that level
it is always easier to attack
so knights the g3 now the knight is
being threatened
bishop captures and f3 will be uh black
up a piece so knight to g3 now the queen
defends the knight
and here we have bishop to d6 offering a
trade of dark square bishops again
uh here uh e5 does uh does go a long way
because
uh you can never capture this or rather
you shouldn't maybe
because if you capture with this then
the bishop falls and
you cannot capture with the knight
because the knight is pinned so you
could capture with the bishop but it's
not
all that impressive for example bishop
captures an f3 queen captures you're
going to capture on e5 now
and if d captures now you recapture with
queen captures here and you get this
position where
black is up a pawn also uh white's king
is a bit uh bit
open uh but uh still uh you still have
to
uh feel good about going into this end
game
so instead just continuing development
with bishop to d6
and here charlie trades with bishop
captures queen captures and now
bishop back to e2 as uh the knight is
still pinned so bishop to e2
now you can move the knight and here we
have f6 and f6 is a very good move by
ludwig
uh the thing is uh you want to start
attacking and although it seems
reasonable to
go h5 h4 and h5 is in fact the strongest
move recommended by the engine
knight g5 is uh simply too problematic
uh for ludwig because now
uh not only is uh well
the attack not happening but h4 is not
possible because knight captures on f7
comes with a with a monster royal fork
here
the queen and both rooks would be under
attack so here ludwig prevents this by
playing f6 he takes away the g5 square
from charlie's knight and here we have
queen to b3
uh going after that uh going after that
queen side and
there doesn't seem to be a problem here
on the king's side so here h5
now now starting with the idea as the g5
square is no longer available
and now knight to e4 charlie is a
material but he needs to
place a play a few very good moves to
consolidate and the next few moves from
both players are simply the absolute
best
so here knight the e for attacks
ludwig's queen and here the situation on
the clock is two
to some two and a half minutes for
charlie and five minutes for ludwig so
charlie has to
uh pick up the pace if he wants to enjoy
his uh
uh h his extra material we have queen to
f4
the only good move for ludwig now
threatens to pick up the pick up the
knight here as it's attacked
twice and now knight to c5 a brilliant
move that threatens checkmate queen
captures and b7 will be checkmate and
the knight also covers the escape square
that is the d7 square
and now again only one good move for
ludwig here and he finds it
knights to a5 attacks the queen and also
defends against checkmate that the b7
square is now defended
and here it's very hard to find the
absolute best move but
the thing is now you have to go back the
knight is attacked twice and
the queen to d1 is the only uh only good
move here
and it's not even this is hard to play
because it looks it looks ugly for
example e5 and
what are you doing i mean the the rook
is about to
come crashing through the d file but the
point is after a few
excellent moves a rookie one and let's
say bishop h3 threatening check and mate
you have this bishop to f1 and this is
how white survives but it's still
such an ugly position for example you
can check your king h2
and now the bishop is attacked twice you
have to capture captures captures and
you get this position
uh where black should be better but you
know
at least at least white survives so
instead after this knight to a5 we have
queen to a4 by charlie
he decides to give up this knight for
for this knight also
uh if this bishop moves from the defense
of the e6 pawn maybe there's some knight
captures an e6 action going on
so here bishop captures on f3 uh we have
bishop captures on f3
and now comes b6 this is how uh ludwig
decided to play it he wanted to defend
his knight
um before capturing the bishop here but
capturing the bishop is actually winning
on the spot
and the problem is if charlie goes uh
queen captures on a 5 3 game material
equality then rook h6 and the game is
over there is no defending against this
so instead after bishop captures an f3
like we said b6 was played
but now uh it's actually charlie who's
winning but
the winning move is not an easy one to
find so feel free to pause the video
here
and try to find the only winning move
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh elusive idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
actually bishop to g2
your bishop is under attack you move it
and that's it white is just
up up material and there is no good way
for black to
take advantage of this point is after h4
threatening some queen uh queen g4 and
h3 ideas
uh you can simply play bishop to h3
block the pawn and now go
after this pawn it's it's too dangerous
to go after the spawn for example if
knight captures an e6 attacks the rook
and the queen
you can play queen g4 then threaten h3
and black is already gaining something
but after bishop h3
uh it's already a different story if
rook to d5 trying to get the rook in
uh for example rook to g5 now it's
actually okay now knight captures on e6
guards the g5 square
and there is no attack and the queen is
also under attack over
these three squares are covered so the
queen uh has to go back
and if queen d6 you then play c4 and
then the entire
position is just terrible uh the rook is
under attack if you move the rook then
we're gonna move the knight
probably capture that rook with a
discovery sorry about that
just a second
ah it it is not the mailman it's it's
the elena
uh so like we said uh this would be
absolutely crushing for white
but a knight bishop to g2 is not an easy
move to find so here
charlie went for the immediate knight
captures on e6
and now yes he's attacking the queen
he's attacking the rook
however uh there is something else here
uh
queen captures on f3 and this is not a
problem knight captures on the e8 we
have rook capture 78 and now
rook 8 to e1 so this is all
uh this has all been played like really
really well
and even though white is up the exchange
it's still very scary if black
gets the attack going if those pawns
start matching forward if this rook
somehow finds a way into the attack
uh it's gonna be gonna be pretty scary
so here uh we have
king the b7 and getting the king away
from the from the back rank the problem
is if you start with
this going after this idea then queen to
e8
check is also a possibility that's the
problem and after this check
you have to go queen b7 and then queen
to e4
not only prevents the rook from going
here because it's spin but also
threatens the queen trait and you don't
really have an option here because the
rook is also hanging so that's how
that's why this rook the e1 by charlie
is is such a good move
it prevents rook to d5 which would be
crushing for
uh for black so here king b7
he gets the king out of the way but now
comes rook to e7
yeah charlie now uh uh goes for for this
very nice rook lift rook to e7
and now g5 ludwig starts uh attacking on
the king's side we have queen
back to c2 uh trying to get the queen
over to e4 this check
uh would trade queens and if the queens
get traded off then it's simply two
rooks against the rook and the knight
and it's a winning end game
and also the problem uh there's this um
all right
uh sorry meadow has a new friend and he
sometimes comes over so
okay he decided to come over now uh
so he's gonna he's gonna help us out
analyze this game so after this queen to
c2 move
uh we have knight the c6 okay away from
the keyboard
knights the c6 now of course uh if the
queen comes to e4 it's not with
check but the problem is it's still the
absolute best move for white if queen to
e4
uh then uh you have to trade uh because
what else are you going to play the
knight cannot move the knight is pinned
and here you you kind of do have to
trade captures captures and then it's
just a much better position for
white so uh this could have been played
but it seems that uh with this knight to
f6
uh ludwig tricked charlie a little bit
but charlie still goes
after rook to f7 so now uh he he put his
rook behind this f6 pawn
he wants to bring the queen in and maybe
start eliminating those pawns but
he now gives uh ludwig the opportunity
uh to go for a perpetual and if
lightweight wishes so queen to g4
definitely ensures a perpetual
if king h2 then queen h4 check we have
to go back and forth and check check
check
and it's a check by by constantly
delivering it's a three-fold repetition
basically
uh so after this quinta
h4 check variation that didn't happen we
go back to rook to f7 and now
g4 ludwig decides to go for uh for
for checkmate and he wants to start
pushing those king side pawns even
further so here
we have queen to h7 now charlie is the
one who's threatening this c7 pawn
and now rook the c8 defending this is
all played very well and now queen
captures on h5 not only stopping the
attack
but also preventing g3 because now the
queen would be hanging
so here uh ludwig starts chasing the
white rook we have knight to d8
attacking the rook rook to g7
and now knights the e6 again attacking
the rook here
but now it's not a problem as uh charlie
plays the absolute best move and that is
queen capture some g4 you don't care
about the rook because the queen is
hanging
and here you don't really have a a good
move you
either trade queens or you go all the
way back and then suffer in a
worse position uh practically it's
probably best to avoid a queen trade
since uh you're gonna be down material
uh but they were both extremely low on
time here under a minute i believe
so charlie uh this uh ludwig decided to
trade here we have captures captures and
now it's
two rooks against a knight and the rook
with f5
challenging the rook and rook to h for
now we have rooked the g8 check finally
this rook joins the attack
now king to h1 ah we have knights to g5
now with ideas of bringing the knight to
f3
but charlie again finds the absolute
best move rook to g1
and now the knight is pinned it's gonna
get attacked one more time and you're
gonna be
losing material here so a lot of it goes
for the only
move that he has available knight to f3
attacks both of the rooks but now it's
basically just a trade of a pair of
rooks so captures captures
and now king to g1 uh we have knight
back to f3 with
check king to g2 and now knights the e1
with
check king to g3 and now knight to d3
it's still five points to four
uh and maybe black can hold this but
it's going to be very hard so rook to f8
going after the pawn here now f4 with
check
so uh deciding at uh or push back the
the white king even further
uh but the problem is in positions like
these uh you're up
a pawn and you don't mind you you can't
actually play this rook captures an f4
move because then after captures
captures you up two pawns
in a completely winning king and pawn
end game so instead after this f4 check
we have came to g4 by charlie
and now not going after knight captures
an f2 which
could give black some fighting chance
but instead
ludwig starts bringing the king into the
game king c6 and now even
f3 uh so getting the pawn out of harm's
way
and now king to d5 ludwig does the
correct thing in the end game you want
to improve the activity of your king we
have rook captures on f4 now and this is
the quickest way
uh as now charlie does what what he
could have done a few moves ago we have
knight captures king captures and now
it's five points to three of course
completely winning
we have king to e6 now king to e4
gaining opposition
and preparing to push the pass pawn so
here we have king to d6 uh and now
f4 we have king to e6 f5 with check king
to f6
now king to f4 again charlie gains the
opposition
king to f7 and now king to e5 we have
king to e7 gaining opposition but not a
problem f6
check king of seven and again king f5
gaining opposition
so now the king has to move you could
also waste some moves
by by pushing the pawns but it's pretty
pointless as a white is also up a pawn
here so
you will not be able to be you will not
be able to blockade anything
king to f8 uh ended now comes king to e6
black gains the opposition king eight
but just f7 check
king to f8 and now king to f6 and if
this was the
uh case without black having and any
pawns actually on the queen side it'd be
a stalemate so maybe
a good practical decision would have
been to maybe try and sacrifice
all of these pawns and try and trick
charlie into
getting into stalemate uh but okay it is
as it is we have c6 now and
came to e6 we have c5 uh attacking the
d4 pawn
not just b not b4 b3 uh
both players are wasting some pawn moves
we have a5 and now
finally charlie gets another uh pawn to
be
uh a pass pawn and now this pawn is
becoming a queen
we have b5 and now d6 uh we have b4
now attacking the c3 pawn but just d7
charlie correctly doesn't waste time on
this pawn
b captures on c3 and now just d8 and
bring a queen into the game with check
king g7
queen to f6 check now we have king to f8
and now
uh okay this is checkmate this is
checkmate uh also
uh but charlie decides to uh play play a
few more moves we have queen to
e7 check king to g7 and now f8 queen
delivering a double check so both the
queens are checking the white king
king to g6 and now queen f to f6 this is
with chuck
king to h5 and now queen e to g7
preparing checkmate uh we have c2 ludwig
very lucky very close uh to promoting
his pawn to a queen but here comes queen
f2h6 and with this move
charlie delivers checkmate and the first
game goes to charlie and
what a game it was so uh the more games
have been played in this matchup if you
guys are interested we can check out uh
some of those games as well but
this has been uh very very very very
good and very instructive
and um okay they've missed a couple of a
couple of better lines uh
when you know there was uh there was a
skirmish on the board but
um all in all this was a very impressive
game and uh
the games are uh becoming of a much
higher quality
than in the first first pog champs
championship then of course in the
second it was better than the first and
now
uh it's um the games are again of much
higher quality so who knows in uh
in pogchamps edition 20 players might be
rated for 2250 2300 who knows
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said if you're
interested in
the scandinavian defense check out the
link in the description below
and yeah if you have any of your other
favorite games that were
nice such as this one do share them in
the description in the comment section
use the hashtag suggestion
and i'm gonna i'm gonna go through your
suggestions and see if if we
uh can check out uh some of the other
games that we can show
so uh once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank uh sandeep
menon
ezra uh and i didn't meet you uh balance
tanka
and uh hunter fike for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day